the age Spider-Man a Golden Compass
promoting atheism from botched
adaptations to culturally insensitive
remakes here are the movies that were
bad enough to kill an entire franchise
before Sony even released their second
installment of The Amazing Spider-Man
story both the third and fourth films
were announced in 2013. with creatives
Alex kurtzman Roberto Aussie and Jeff
pinkner set to reunite with director
Mark Webb to expand Peter Parker's story
they aims to expand the greater Amazing
Spider-Man universe as well soon Venom
Sinister Six and other spidey-themed
projects were thrust into developments
as Sony set their eyes on building their
own Marvel Universe to rival Disney's
growing Marvel Cinematic Universe it's
too dangerous after an underwhelming
performance by The Amazing Spider-Man 2
Sony made a deal with Marvel Studios
granting the studio usage of the
Spider-Man character albeit it's a d8
and rebooted version this new Spider-Man
now played by Tom Holland instead of
Andrew Garfield appeared first in
Captain America Civil War before
starring in his own film the Sony and
Marvel Studios collaboration Spider-Man
homecoming from there Holland went on to
Star Wars Peter Parker in two more
Spider-Man films and continued appearing
alongside the Avengers as well though
The Amazing Spider-Man universe didn't
happen Venom was still made that's
Garfield's Spider-Man returned for
Spider-Man no way home nearly a decade
after The Amazing Spider-Man came out
the character's story was rounded out
leaving many hopeful that we'll see this
version of the wall crawler again
Johnny Depp might be a screen chameleon
but audiences were not on board with him
suiting up as the Native American
character Tonto in Disney's The Lone
Ranger Disney's attended a western
franchise to rival and eventually
succeed their Pirates of the Caribbean
series tragically failed upon the film's
initial release despite Deb's
involvements and the inclusion of the
original Pirates trilogy director Gore
vabinski The Lone Ranger didn't ride
very far according to E news a film was
expected to result in sequels but it was
ultimately pandas racially insensitive
among other critical gripes and
considered a massive flop at the box
office in response Deb himself spoke out
against a critical complaints claiming
that the Lone Ranger's failure was
ultimately connected to faulty
expectations that were off from the
start produced sir Jerry Bruckheimer
agreed with depth sentiments arguing
their critics for more concern with the
budget and scoped in the picture itself
brockheimer was so sure of the film's
quality that he predicted within a few
years critics would come around to the
would-be Blockbuster in a big way as we
have yet to see any review retractions
or hear Whispers of new Lone Ranger
stories it seems viewers just weren't
interested in this updated Tale
at a time when children's fantasy
stories like Harry Potter and The
Chronicles of Narnia were performing
pretty well an adaptation of Philip
Pullman's dreamy story World seemed like
a sure thing but considering its
reportedly Hefty price tag of 180
million dollars The Golden Compass
didn't live up to expectations taking in
just 70 million dollars in domestic
sales furthermore the film like the
original novels was played by the
Catholic Church's Proclamation that the
picture promoted atheism to Young
viewers though Harry Potter suffered
similar criticisms The Wizarding World
had become a virtually Unstoppable
cultural phenomenon leaving little room
for a lesser known franchise at The
Golden Compass to get its sea legs
director Chris whites took the Atlantic
to counter accusations that he neglected
the story's religious tenets but the
damage was already done two planned
sequels the subtle knife and the Amber
Spyglass were put on hold indefinitely
and the adaptation rights eventually
reverted back to Philip Pullman over 10
years after the failed attempt at a film
Trilogy HBO Revisited Pullman's Universe
with the series his dark materials which
we've also received much better by
audiences and critics alike the series
run three seasons covering each of
Pullman's novels of the same name
read a tongue-in-cheek action thriller
about a group of retired CIA operatives
brought back into action by an old foe
was just kooky and action-packed enough
to hit the right tone with critics and
make a nice mint at the box office
encouraged by Soul star cast and a warm
reception to the public the studio is
quick to green light red too and began
working on a script for red 3 shortly
before the first sequel's release it
seems like a no-brainer after all
however Red 2 was a letdown for the
studio scorned by reviewers and skips by
moviegoers making more headlines for
Willis's awkward promotional interviews
than anything else though the third
installment was poised to go in
production just months after red 2's
release red 3 was never greenlit instead
the series screenwriting Duo John and
ericober took their story to NBC in the
hopes of launching a TV series when
they've failed to pan out a deadline
reported that Lionsgate decided to
reboot the red series for the Indian
market instead the effectively scrapping
its plans for another follow-up to the
surprise hit it's been crickets for the
franchise ever since
meant to be a love letter to the
original Christopher reeveled Superman
films of the late 1970s and early 1980s
Superman returned sadly fell a bit short
helmed by director Brian Singer who
jumped ship on X-Men the Last Stand in
order to tackle Superman's big screen
return Superman Returns did not meet the
initial expectations of anybody involved
not only did the film fail to bring in
the box office recedes the studio was
hoping for it was also criticized for
being too similar to The Originals many
viewers apparently wanted a 21st century
Superman to engage in some more Modern
Combat while Superman Returns has been
viewed more favorably in recent years
the initial reception killed any plans
of an immediate sequel over a decade
later Superman actor Brandon Routh done
the cape once more this time on the
small screen for the Arrow versus crisis
on infinite Earth's event according to
slash film DC Comics CCO Jim Lee was
instrumental in Ralph's television
return as Superman which feels very much
like an epilogue for Superman Returns
fairy tale adaptations might be all the
rage but almost no one liked what
happened in Paramount's Handel and
Gretel witch Hunters the film which
starred Jeremy Renner and Gemma Arterton
followed Monster hunting grown-up
versions of the titular characters while
the idea was interesting it didn't
exactly Captivate audiences who
criticized the film for its overuse of
violence this Van Helsing wannabe was
widely panned by critics and ignored by
North American movie goers so witch
Hunters 2 which was originally expected
to see release in 2016 never came to
light in 2015 deadline reported that
Paramount decided to forego any plans
for a Hansel and Gretel sequel in favor
of a possible television adaptation
unfortunately the witch Hunters never
made it to the small screen and to this
day there's been no news on whether
we'll ever see these witch-killing
siblings team up on camera again
the early 2000s are filled with plenty
of fantasy adaptations some were good
like the Lord of the Rings and the first
installment of The Chronicles of Narnia
others were bad like Aragon producers
taken the Beloved novel by Christopher
Paolini and turning it into a generic
Hollywood Blockbuster was the last straw
for fans of The Inheritance cycle the
overwhelmingly negative reviews sealed
the fate of this fantasy series before
was given the chance to soar and the
Planned Aragon sequels were quickly
canceled fans of paldini's original
novels hoped for more faithful
adaptations in the future and after
years of waiting they're about to get
their wish water sequels to Eragon were
never made variety reported in 2022 that
a Disney plus streaming series based on
the inheritance cycle is in development
with Paolini stepping in as co-writer
time to return the favor howlini
confirmed the announcement in a tweet
where he also thanked fans who supported
him throughout the entire process of
getting the reboot off the ground with
their Aragon and Percy Jackson reboot
plans afoot it seems like Disney is
attempting to build a larger fantasy
library of Their Own
after Sherlock Holmes on a Man from
Uncle director guy Richie took his turn
at the King Arthur Legend in King Arthur
Legend Of The Sword and the results
speak for themselves starring Charlie
Hunnam as the titular warrior king
legend of the sword was a lackluster
fantasy flick that failed to meet the
expectations of everyone involved
although the trailers promise an
exciting Led Zeppelin infused action
rump audiences were largely
disinterested after a series of poor
critical reviews though the audience
responses were largely positive the
negative Buzz killed the movie's
momentum and any attempts at a sequel
before King Arthur died in box office
combat co-writer Joby Harold originally
envisioned the legend of the sword as
the first of a six-part shared Universe
of action fantasies set in the Medieval
Era while Harold was a bit too ambitious
in the Modern Age of Hollywood where
everything must have some sort of
franchise or sequel potential it's
understandable that there were more
stories they wanted to tell nevertheless
Richie's version of King Arthur was
mortally wounded and it seems unlikely
to recover
no remake was arguably more necessary
than Tim Burton's Planet of the Apes a
darker burton-ish fantasy version of the
original science fiction classic a 2001
Planet of the Apes follows most of the
same beats as the original the film
begins with a human astronaut ending up
on a strange planet where apes have
evolved and humans are the slaves only
for him to eventually find out that sub
planet is actually Earth while the
Cliffhanger ending is a bit different
than the originals even the questions we
had weren't pressing enough to Warrant a
sequel despite the film's box office
success the critical disdain for
Burton's Planet of the Apes combined
with the director's own lack of interest
in continuing the project close the book
on this short-lived Venture instead the
franchise pivoted entirely rebooting
through a series of prequels that
chronicled the Apes rise as Earth's
dominant species from 2011's Rise of the
planets of the apes onward the franchise
has developed into something more
interesting than anything Burton's
reboot ever did with another sequel on
the way the 2001 reboot is now a nearly
forgotten black sheep of the franchise
few comic book movies have damaged the
franchise so badly as Joel Schumacher's
Batman and Robin despite the Stellar
cast the veteran director and backing by
Warner Brothers the fourth Batman
picture was nothing short of an absolute
disaster more akin to Adam West Batman
from the 1960s the modern depictions of
The Dark Knight Batman and Robin was
hated by audiences and critics alike and
for good reason although the film did
well financially even the Stars
themselves hope to distance themselves
from Batman and Robin with George
Clooney calling the film a waste of
money needless to say plans for his
follow-up Batman triumphant were quickly
canceled years later Schumacher publicly
apologized for making the movie of
course Batman wouldn't stay down Forever
After the 1997 disaster Christopher
Nolan rebooted Batman via his Dark
Knight trilogy with Christian Bale in
the leading role after that Zack Snyder
reimagined the character for Batman v
Superman and his version of Justice
League was Ben Affleck as a Caped
Crusader most recently of course Batman
appeared on screens via Matt Reeves new
Leeming to the Batman film series
starring Robert Pattinson in 2023s the
flash both afflecks Batman and Michael
Keaton's version from Tim Burton's
movies returned to the cow and there's
even another Batman movie The Brave and
the Bold in development
when it comes to animation to live
action adaptations big budget
Blockbusters can be pretty Hit or Miss
sadly the biggest Swiss and M Night
shyamalan's interpretation of avatar The
Last Airbender is that it was absolutely
nothing like the original animated
series often considered one of the worst
films ever made The Last Airbender
butchers many details of the original
series including the pronunciation of
the titular character's name I'm Ang are
you the Avatar wrong Not only was this
Nickelodeon adaptation just generally
terrible it was one of the lowest points
of shyamalan's filmography not even
decent box office numbers could save him
from This Disaster and it proved a major
blow to the director's career ever since
the failure that was The Last Airbender
fans have hoped for a better live-action
adaptation of the Beloved animated
series after years of waiting Netflix
has swooping in to hopefully save the
day whether or not Netflix's upcoming
adaptation is incredible or not and will
no doubt be loads better than the first
attempt hopefully they've learned from
the last airbender's mistakes and will
follow the Animated Series a bit more
closely
after the success of Walt Disney
Pictures and modern media had with their
adaptations of the Lion The Witch in the
wardrobe and Prince Caspian the third
Chronicles of Narnia films seemed sure
to succeed though Disney got replaced
with 20th Century Fox for the third
installment's production much of the
original cast returned for The Voyage of
the Dawn Treader given that the novel is
a fun favorite hopes for high as a
feature set sail unfortunately the movie
was a bit too generous for the events of
the book for viewers liking after mixed
reviews from both critics and audiences
Narnia Webb reported that Walden media
lost the rights to The Chronicles of
Narnia in 2011. this last thought their
plans to pursue an adaptation of the
prequel novel The Magician's Nephew
though the rights remained in limbo for
a few years Netflix eventually picked
them up and began work on a new series
of films and television shows based on
C.S Lewis's Works sadly there haven't
been any official updates on Netflix's
Narnia developments since 2021
foreign
[Music]